the death of Fidel Castro has sparked a
variety of responses from across the
world their labor leader Jeremy Corbyn
called him a huge figure and praised his
heroism while president-elect Donald
Trump condemned his legacy as one of
firing squads and unimaginable suffering
whether shadow Chancellor John McDonnell
has said that he counts Lenin and
Trotsky as among his heroes and he joins
me now from West London hello to you and
Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy called me described
and Castro was a a huge figure with many
achievements is it appropriate to
describe a man in those terms when we
know that he didn't allow free and fair
elections that he locked up gay men and
that he imprisoned his a political
opponents yes there are very there are
many flaws in the Cuban regime and many
criticisms that many people made
including ourselves but for my
generation if you look back on this the
immense achievement of the Cuban
Revolution this was a country that was
controlled by effectively a kleptocrat
where those extremes of wealth and
poverty no education no health service
and the land controlled by landlords
Wells peasants literally starved and so
the revolution took place and it
redistributed wealth and the land it
introduced an education service and the
health service which was well second to
none in the world in some instances and
so and also supported freedom struggles
in South Africa support the ANC against
our part I and other struggles in Latin
America so it was a beacon of hope for
many people but yes of course there were
flaws and you cannot but criticize those
but again in the face of the blockades
and the opposition from the US the
achievements of the Cuban Revolution
have to be admired a particularly regard
to education health and redistribution
of wealth talk about the achievements in
education it may be true that the regime
helped people to reach but then it told
people what they were and weren't
allowed to read if it was as great as
you say then why didn't they hold free
elections they would have in a landslide
wouldn't it well I think what's
interesting that with the blockade
lifted and Obama as new relationship
with Cuba as well
I think there was you could see a path
towards elections you can see a path
towards a great liberalisation in terms
of literally other basic freedoms and
you can see how the foundations of the
revolution can actually be built upon I
think looking back over all history will
judge that this was a force for good but
yes you've got to be honest about the
criticisms of the regime as well are you
effectively giving Fidel Castro a free
pass because he's left-wing if a
right-wing politician hood acted in this
way particularly with reduce with
respect to people like homosexuals you
would have been first out of the blocks
to criticize them well we were we were
and of course we're not giving a free
pass on issues like that of course not
but you have to judge over all and
you've got to praise where there are
well as I say in immense breakthrough
strictly regard to how they redistribute
wealth and the land the education system
the health system that was inspirational
but of course there are flaws and of
course that has to be criticized but as
I said I think looking at it overall
overall I think in history will judge
that was a force for good when your view
is coming across very strongly there and
mr. McDonald let's move on and talk
about the Autumn Statement
it was a bit of an open goal for you
wasn't it borrowing ballooning another
myth deficit target and yet you couldn't
even get your own MPs to listen to you
they were buried in our mobile things
what went wrong yes I know I've made
this comment elsewhere within the House
of Commons chamber now the speaker has
raised this - during debates what you'll
see happening increasingly is MPs of all
political parties on their mobile phones
either receiving messages or updating
themselves on the commentary that's
going on outside or tweeting out
themselves now I don't make you know I
don't make any judgment on that I think
the general public will have to make
their judgement on that but it seems to
be a new well a new practice over the
last couple of years that's happened in
Parma it's interesting you know it isn't
just Parliament it's other walks of life
as well where that new technology is
used to have almost a continuous
dialogue yourself with people outside of
the main debating chamber or even the
meeting that you're in as I said
up to the public to decide but what was
in well the interesting enough on the
Autumn Statement I think we did go our
messages across very clearly in fact
you've just quoted them back to as we
said that the government on its own
metrics had failed on every target on
debt and deficit and the welfare cap and
on all the other metrics about how the
economy was going in terms of wages
growth and growth and business
investment it was failing on those as
well and I think that message has come
across loud and clear but also I think
there's a real there's a real
disillusionment with what happened on on
Wednesday as well all those promises
from the government about helping that
just about managing were well well all
those promises were basically broken in
fact we're finding that people could
lose up to a couple of thousand pounds a
year now even the so-called living wage
increase was not what was promised and
people people are losing money as a
result of that so it's a I think we did
get the message across on all the
government's metrics and I think it's
increasingly now what we're finding is
that the government's Autumn Statement
proposals are being exposed and promises
being broken you've raised one as well
which was hidden in the commentary
around the Autumn Statement which is
about the triple lock on patient's
pension is now who you know as a result
I believe as a result of the the Labour
government that was in place actually
have been lifted largely out of poverty
many of them still struggle but we're
being improved a lot of pensioners in
our society dramatically particularly
under Labour government but now the
triple lock is threatened and as a
result of that what we're seeing is
pensioners fearful about their futures
you talk about the public eye being the
opinion that matters to you but actually
if you look at some of the polls things
are pretty gloomy on your own ratings
sky data say that 36 percent of people
trust Philip Hammond to run the economy
compared to just seven percent saying
you 7 percent that's pretty low yes but
look back on the polls that's continuing
poll since 2007 2008 and literally
that's been this case all the way
through and that's because I think it's
because labour in power during the
period of the crash that didn't cause
the crash that's a the narrative that
was developed and it was wrong you know
the the the deficit before the
didn't call the crash it was crashed
that caused the deficit so all the way
through there's been that polling lead
on economic credibility for the
Conservatives who took over after us in
in 2010 but again even back to 1997
before Tony Blair and Gordon Brown were
elected again they still weren't ahead
of the rope there weren't the head of
the Tories in terms of economic
credibility and that's unfortunately
this position of opposition parties I
think actually though I trust polls much
these day I don't think people trust
polls much these days but I think
underneath all of this is a can increase
in disillusionment with the promises of
this government increasingly a growing
growing demand for change I'm not sure
you can put it all down to historical
issues they're 20% of Labor voters who
voted for labor in 2015 still say that
they trust you so that's a quite a large
number who don't say that they trust you
with managing the economy what are you
going to do to try and sort out that
trust what are the really difficult
decisions that you are prepared to take
well what we're trying to do now is
raise the whole level of economic debate
beyond what it's been up until now and
get to the real truth of the matter the
reason that we've got problems at the
moment facing brexit and it came in the
figures that we will reveal last week
there's a hundred and twenty billion
pound deficit that we're facing at this
rate what does that come from
first of all less than half is coming
from the threat of brexit the rest is
coming from the mismanagement of the
economy since 2010 how has that been
mismanaged well first of all an unfair
taxation system where there's been tax
cuts for the wealthy and unfortunately
cuts in terms of benefits and public
services for the rest of us in addition
to that I think really a failure to
attack old tax evasion and tax avoidance
avoidance so the key issue is first of
all you get a fair taxation system
second once you've got a fair taxation
system you can start investing your
economy now last Thursday last Wednesday
we heard from the Chancellor that there
will be some investment but nothing on
the scale that's needed and we've had
six wasted years that's why we're so
unprepared for brexit and ill-equipped
what we need is a fair taxation
system then you use those resources to
actually grow the economy by investment
and as a result of growing the economy
you can then you can afford the public
services that you need let's talk
specifically about policy because you've
been very clear that labor needs to be a
government in waiting with policies
ready to be taken off the shelf in the
event of a general election which there
is a chance of course make sure that
there could be a general election so
what exactly is Labour's policy on the
biggest issue of all on brexit are you
in favor of staying in the single market
being in the customs union or of being
outside so that you can strike free
trade deals on your own okay well we set
out red lines I did a speech a week
after the referendum so we were very
clear then the red lines of these let me
run through them with you first of all
access to the single market that's what
we want access to single markets in the
single market is that right you're
saying that you want to be in the single
market all right are you saying that you
want to be in the single market we want
access to the single market access
ideally I'd like membership but I don't
think we can go that far in terms of
what political support there is so
access to the single market as a minimum
we want also to ensure that we get
access to our financial services because
they're a key sector for our economy we
want also to preserve the rights of UK
citizens in the EU as well as yiyu
citizens here we also want to protect
the regulations that we have now from
Europe both in terms of employment and
the environmental protection and then
finally I want to secure our continuing
involvement in the European Investment
Bank because we get a good will we get a
good deal at the European Investment
Bank particularly in terms of investment
in our regions now there the red lines
we set out within a week of a referendum
now we're saying to the government on a
number of these issues we can work in
the interest of the country we can work
in a bipartisan way putting country
above party but we need to know where
they're going what is their objective
what is their strategy and that hasn't
been forthcoming final question john
macdonald and do you think that donald
trump's election is good news for jeremy
corbyn because it shows that people want
to go for anti-establishment candidates
or is it actually bad news because even
when
people don't business-as-usual it
indicates that they're going for
candidates on the right
rather than those on the left it's
interesting that I think the Trump
election does demonstrate that people
are absolutely frustrated with the
existing system and do want change but
the type of change that Trump has put
forward in his campaign statements is
certainly not the route that any well
any progressive or modern country would
want to go go down that path and I think
what we need to do in this country is
recognize that actually people don't
feel they're getting a fair deal they
don't believe that the government is
acting in their interests at the moment
that they do feel that there's an elite
establishment particularly in
Westminster that's completely ignoring
them and what they want now is a
radically fairer and more democratic and
more equal society and I think Jeremy
Corbyn offers that hope Joe McDonald
thank you